raga stiamo andando al tokyo game show
c'è tipo un click però di tokyo a
giudicare dalla gente che c'è in fila
alla metro questa è la meta
ci sarà un po di gente semmai agli usi
che non ci vado perché c'è troppa gente
che fa la fila per l'inter ma data van
loan ci stanno mango youtuber e c'è la
madonna allora stefano e sasha sono
entrati nello stand di switch per rubare
rubare avete capito bene il cuscino di
qui vediamo se riescono nel loro intento
la preda e lì
occhio che qui è tutto vetrato ecco
ma via via via via via bravo il nostro
italiano giusto la madonna papa ma 12
porti
grazie se non ci fossi tu come guida
turistica saremmo ancora a cinisello
balsamo stiamo andando ad un party di
youtube che organizzato sempre a
giuseppe vedremo come so che sull'acqua
ma che caso la maglia macchia scusami
uno zaino dove metti i soldi di cui
veramente c'è light yagami che prende le
firme pochi si coltivano le maglie di
cosa e finché tubimar magro tenchio sì
però fra delle calze con le infradito no
e ti perdono tutto però porca [ __ ] le
calze con infradito
comunque ci stanno imbarcando stanno
imbarcando in questo momento dobbiamo
posare le scarpe perché siamo su una
barca sul tatami basta farmi video
mentre facci video c'è una roba
incredibile
questa è una barca vi rendete conto e
vabbè se diamo giuseppe c'è una puzza di
piedi che fa paura però vieni salvo
vieni giuseppe che si è integrato
benissimo è cresciuta la barbetta parte
della bar del vecchio tanto vecchio
giuseppe come ti senti vecchio oggi
qualche foglietto bianco c'è qualche
paletto di grafici hanno servito con
sushi pregiato il vino bianco tutto
questo che ci offre youtube perché you
tube si tiene il 45 per cento
45 per cento del cp era 40 per cento
ladri abbiamo cenando su una barca sul
tatami mentre la barca sta andando cioè
è la cosa più incredibile che abbia mai
visto
ma fra ancora rivoli [ __ ] grande ma che
è incredibile la fronte di giuseppe
fantastica
la cosa divertente gli altri youtuber
registrano registrano costa videocamera
gigantesca da 4.000 euro io sono una
sgangherata e fa veramente ridere il
pene con una faccia così puoi
accompagnare solo febbraio va bene drive
my lai e valigie paglia il culo ai meno
sfida con quindi addio che ci ha più di
un milione di iscritti
allora devi picchiare quando lui non
allo scudo lui quando ti picchia se ne
va allo scudo ad aie ok
ma domani ha detto devi colpire quando
la lo scoop stagione la sfida in italia
ma perché le fa il bosco abituiamo il
premio braga poverino mi dispiace c'è
rimasto malissimo
ecco queste le caratterizza alla fine
avesse vinto il tempo cattivo
[Musica]
si no
ma la
no
ciao milan
[Applauso]
[Musica]
giuseppe se ci tuffiamo adesso se ci sia
o nota posto cartello che cosa è 9 non è
8 sicuramente ragazzi siamo
all'osservatorio da qua si vede bene
tokyo c'è veramente si vede bene la
skyline di tokyo d'acqua riesco a vedere
l'incrocio dall'alto quello dove
l'incrocio più trafficato del mondo
non smetterò mai di riprendere questa
scena perché ogni volta che scatta il
semaforo la gente si accalca dietro le
strisce da tutti i lati di questi
quattro lati i dirigenti e questo non si
vede perché coperto e ogni volta che
scatta il semaforo l'incrocio si riempie
di gente l'incrocio più trafficato al
mondo ragazzino io per quanto l'abbia
già ripreso mille volte ci ho fatto già
mille foto continuerà a riprenderlo
perché mi affascina troppo
non so perché se fossi stata una
youtuber giapponese avrei fatto un
raduno nell'incrocio di shibuya tu sei
e cazzo e bianco
se si tolga si tolga il cazzo grazie
dice non comporta anche io no non ci
posso credere a xavi la bottiglia oddio
deve evitare le chiazze di piscio
bertello che spesso ai pisciato sul
serio nel cestino
ma cosa perché c'è tuttavia guarda è
questo ragazzo era ufficialmente
l'ultimo video del giappone di o finiti
tutti spero vi sia piaciuto questo
viaggio a me è piaciuto un sacco spero
di avervi fatto vedere tutto il
possibile compreso sasha che piscia nel
cestino bene e la particolarità di tutto
questo è che dovevo tagliarmi i capelli
prima di partire per il giappone sono
andati in giappone ci siamo stati quasi
un mese sono tornato da oltre una
settimana e ancora non gli ho sbagliati
alla situazione sta degenerando max
sticazzi però vi sia piaciuto cose sul
momento mi piace anche la comunità cosa
che ci siete
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
[Musica]
no